just hours after the surprised release
of the hostages held for Days by
inmates Ecuador Security Forces moved in
to regain control of the country's
prisons in the coastal city of machala
soldiers entered the facility
encountering literal resistance inside
police footage showed how the officers
found weapons hidden in the Jail's walls
similar scenes repeated in other
detention centers across the country
in the city of laa half naked inmates
were forced to sing the national anthem
while policemen raised Ecuador's
[Music]
flag restoring order inside the
country's dangerous prisons is a
priority for president Danielle NOOA
after he declared a state of internal
conflict in the country earlier last
week it gave the military sweeping
powers to confront criminal gangs
responsible for an unprecedent ented
wave of violence that shocked the
country following the government's
initial
Crackdown in recent years successive
governments have helplessly witnessed
the expansion of drug cartels in a
country that has become one of the main
logistical hubs for cocaine trafficking
retaking control of the prisons will
likely help quell this immediate
emergency but most analysts here agree
that addressing the underlying causes of
Ecuador's crisis will be a much more
difficult task ask political analyst
Gabriela panana says the recently
elected NOOA has so far showed little in
terms of a plan to address drug cartel's
infiltration in state
institutions as long as we do not have a
system where the judges prosecutors
police and military are all truly in the
service of the country and not at the
service of criminals will not be able to
resolve this issue well others fear just
how far the military might go
what usually happens and has happened
not only in Ecuador and Latin America is
that when you ask the Armed Forces for
results at any cost the Armed Forces
achieve them at any cost that is why it
seems important to me that we remain
watchful and that we set limits on the
use of
force no Gambit offers him the political
opportunity to try to Dent the criminal
organization's reach Al
alaz make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer